so in this video we're going to talk
about using iodine
topical iodine for skin tags
now you can also use this for warts as
well now there's some real interesting
data which i'll put the links down below
that shows that using topical iodine can
inactivate
the papillomavirus which is behind
warts and skin tags
now as far as the relationship between
this virus causing skin tags
they don't know this for a fact but i
think that this virus is behind skin
tags simply because
skin tags respond to iodine topical
iodine
now the type of iodine i would recommend
for this is povidone iodine it's an
over-the-counter iodine
you can get it anywhere and you just put
a little drop
on the skin tag and do that for several
days in a row you can put a little
band-aid over it
and watch what happens now you can also
do the same thing with a wart
human papilloma viruses are the most
common sexually transmitted
infection this virus is also behind
cervical cancer now because of the fact
that iodine is
antibacterial antiviral
anti-yeast anti-fungal anti-mold
it would make sense to me that if you
had enough iodine in your diet
that it could potentially help you
reduce the risk for some of these
problems because what you have to
realize is that a lot of these viruses
can go in and out of remission they can
stay
dormant if there's enough protection
and trace minerals like iodine is one
way to keep these viruses
in the dormant remission stage and
there's quite a few
other trace minerals that also will help
put viruses back in remission and zinc
is also at the top of the list
now as far as warts and skin tags i
think it's a no-brainer to use a
topical iodine all right try it out and
comment down below
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help